solide zweistellig aber wiederum
deutlich hinter den grünen wird die afg
mutmaßlich wie viel ich wie viele
ähnlich gelagerte parteien in der
europäischen union einen erfolgreichen
wahl abend verbringen möglicherweise
werden sie dann in summe ebenfalls das
zünglein an der waage spielen können bei
der wahl des kommissionspräsidenten
dementsprechend selbstbewusst geht
beispielsweise spitzenkandidat jörg
menten in dieser letzten tage des
wahlkampfes heute in naumburg an der
saale
wahlkampf wahlkampf lassen sie mich das
sagen macht spaß weil das bringt mich
gerade auch um mich aus diesem
paralleluniversum brüssel so ein
bisschen raus denn da ist man
tatsächlich sehr weit weg von menschen
und das liebe ich nicht und im wahlkampf
da ist man ganz dicht dran an menschen
und das liebe ich das heißt das ist
willkommene gelegenheit unter leute zu
kommen und auch zu hören wo der schuh
drückt was sind die eigentlichen themen
denn das ist genau das was in brüssel
fehlt wenn man da arbeitet dann kriegt
man nicht mehr viel mit von draußen mann
ist in so einer rundum gepimpten
wohlfühlwelt und da richten sich viele
sehr sehr gemütlich einen wir verlieren
dann den bezug zu dem was der
eigentliche grund ist warum sie dort
sind nämlich um probleme zu lösen jemand
öffentlich lösen muss und wie man
vielleicht doch nur auf europäischer
ebene lösen kann und lassen sie mich
auch sagen ich mache wahlkampf auch
deswegen gern weil dafür die das statt
was im parlament stattfinden müsste aber
nicht stattfindet nämlich der diskurs
mit den anderen politischen parteien die
debatten im europäischen parlament haben
alles aber keine diskurs kultur also die
die wunderbaren redeschlachten dem
bundestag wie nicole höchste und andere
sie leben und gründe und erleben dort
und uns selber durchführen das genau das
was im europäischen parlament gar nicht
gibt da hält jeder seine 60 sekunden
vortrag und dann ist ruhe im karton und
einfach der nächste dran das ist
vergleichsweise unspannend ein habe ich
im ganzen wahlkampf noch nicht gesehen
und das ist interessant das will ich
ihnen erzählen der eine das ist manfred
weber wenn sie den ich kennen macht
nichts drei viertel der menschen kennen
den nicht ist auch nicht so wirklich
wichtig aber ich sage es ihnen manfred
weber ist der spitzenkandidat der cdu
csu also der svp-fraktion wie jetzt im
europaparlament heißt und komischerweise
den seh ich nirgends der ist immer nicht
da und ich frage mich warum weil ich
wirklich gerne mal mit dem bisschen
streiten
der erzählt nämlich
von allen fast das meiste dummes zeug
der erzählt zum beispiel dass er wenn er
hat kommissionspräsident werden werden
sollte und das ist ein einziges ziel der
hat kein anderes ziel als junker als
kommissionspräsident zu werden dass er
für den fall dass das gelingt sich ganz
massiv dafür einsetzen wird dass die
erdgas pipeline von russland
erdgasleitung dass die nicht weiter
realisiert wird das die nicht ans netz
geht
das heißt er kündigt nichts anderes als
dass er ihnen schaden will
denn wenn wir etwas in diesem land in
den letzten jahren erlebt haben neben
der migrations krise dann ist eine
völlig verkorkste energiewende runter
angela merkel völlig verkorkst und die
energieversorgungssicherheit steht
wirklich auf dem spiel
und da sage ich ihnen da sage ich ihnen
mit dem weber ist das so eine geschichte
der hat sowieso nicht so sehr mit
deutschland also wir wir sind deutsche
patrioten weber wies unlängst darauf hin
dass er sich zunächst mal als europäer
sehen dann erst als bayer und deutsche
das ist eine position die darf man haben
ich will das nicht verteufeln aber ich
weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht mir geht es
umgekehrt
ich fühle mich zunächst mal als
deutscher und das sehr wohl als
deutscher patriot und dann sehe ich mich
auch als europäer und so und finde ich
ist richtig und über wlan mit verlaub
muss ich sagen der mann ist weder ein
guter europäer noch ein guter deutscher
und auch kein guter bayer er ist ein
guter karriere das ist alles und ich
sage ihnen auch noch etwas mit der neuen
fraktionen die wir da im europaparlament
gerade bilden und auch mit ein bisschen
hilfe von anderen wie zb von viktor
orban wir werden verhindern dass manfred
weber in brüssel kommissionspräsident
wird den karrieristen haben wir da schon
genug wir werden das verhindern und das
werden wir schaffen
ich nehme das immer ein zitat von jean
claude juncker das ist schon alt aber
der mann ist am brüsseler urgestein
er hat mal folgendes gesagt ich zitieren
wir beschließen etwas stellen das dann
in den raum und warten einige zeit ab
was passiert wenn es dann kein großes
geschrei gibt und keine aufstände weil
die meisten gar nicht begreifen was
beschlossen wurde dann machen wir weiter
schritt für schritt bis es kein zurück
mehr gibt ende des zitats das sagt jean
claude juncker und genauso genauso meine
damen und herren wird da gearbeitet und
fragen sie sich einmal selbst wann sie
das letzte mal ein verordnungs oder
gesetzgebungsverfahren aus brüssel aktiv
mitbekommen haben wenn sie ehrlich sind
wahrscheinlich gar nicht das ist ihnen
auch nicht zum vorwurf zu machen weil
das sehr weit weg ist und weil er sehr
komplizierte verfahren sind und man sich
jeden tag damit bestand beschäftigen
kann weil man anderes zu tun hat und das
ist genau das wenn es keinen aufschrei
gibt machen sie weiter und weiter und
weiter
genau das walter ulbricht den die
älteren vielleicht noch kennen
ehemaliger ddr staatsratsvorsitzender
der etwas sehr ähnliches gesagt er hat
gesagt es muss alles demokratisch
aussehen aber wir müssen alles in der
hand haben
das ist ganz ähnlich zu dem was der
junker da gesagt hat und das ist genau
das problem
und glauben sie mir die arbeiten alle
zusammen sie werden am donnerstag zum
beispiel die gelegenheit haben ein
sogenanntes tv-duell tatsächlich er n-tv
duett zu beobachten
zwischen franz zimmermann erster
stellvertretender kommissionspräsident
und eben jean claude juncker eine
entschuldigung und manfred weber dem der
kommissionspräsident werden will
diese beiden sind in wirklichkeit
ziemlich beste freunde wieder alle
ziemlich beste freunde ist sind mit
ausnahme von uns wir sind da die mit
denen man nicht redet und das auch ganz
gut so wenn ich da im club willkommen
geheißen würde dann wüsste ich hätte
etwas falsch gemacht meine damen und
herren nicht dafür gehen wir dahin
[Applaus]
sind die heutigen eliten in brüssel die
das betreiben die uns gegen unsere
willen auf einer reise schicken die wir
gar nicht wollen und noch mal thema
mainz ist da nicht allein die
kommunisten und sozialisten hatte hinter
sich die sozialdemokraten und die
vorgeblich grünen ja selbst die
vorgeblich liberalen und die
christdemokraten die tun nur so als
wendeten sich hätten sie sich dagegen
das tun sie aber gar nicht und um daran
nicht den geringsten zweifel zulassen
wenn wir jetzt mit einer bärenstarken fd
gruppe ins europäische parlament gehen
dann gehen wir genau da hin um genau
diese leute dort aus ihren positionen zu
vertreiben und das werden wir tun und
das werden wir auch schaffen
schritt für schritt und sitz für sitz
mit einer eselsgeduld bis wir sie aus
ihren positionen heraus aber wir machen
dazu lassen sich brauchen denn deren
ganze deren ganzen welt fremde
multikulti agenda die können die
meinetwegen nächtelang in irgendwelchen
linksradikalen zirkeln durch
philosophieren unter einnahme welcher
substanz auch immer ist mir wurscht aber
sie sollen uns freie bürger deutschlands
und europas mit ihren ideologischen
hirngespinsten in ruhe lassen um an
kranken ideologien mit millionen toten
hat mir im zwanzigsten jahrhundert weiß
gott schon mehr als genug
das braucht keine neuauflage wir wenden
uns entschieden gegen jede form von
totalitarismus gegen wirklich jedem uns
meine damen und herren steht ein europa
der vaterländer vor in dem nationale
regionale und kulturelle eigenheiten
geachtet und verteidigt werden
und wenn politiker wie orban salvini
oder strache die nationalen interessen
ihrer länder verteidigen dann verdient
das lob und nicht verachtung
stattdessen habe wenn genau diese leute
auf brüsseler ebene bekämpft die
europäische union lassen sie mich das
sagen muss lernen regionale eigenheiten
nationale eigenheiten zu respektieren
und sich nicht anmaßen und arrogant
darüber hinwegzusetzen kein mensch fragt
sich in brüssel
warum die briten rausgehen die briten
haben aber mehrheitlich mit lief mit
austritt gestimmt und man müsste man
analysieren warum sie das getan haben
dass deswegen getan weil sie ihre
eigenheiten nicht mehr leben durften
weil brüssel ihnen das schritt für
schritt genommen hat und weil die gesagt
haben den wahnsinn verbunden mit der
migrationspolitik von frau merkel das
machen wir nicht mit bevor wir das hier
auch noch bekommen gehen wir lieber das
wir wollen die eu nicht abschaffen die
anderen erzählen wir sagen die anti
europäer wir wollten den decks sydney
wolle man nicht anti europäer sind wir
schon gar nicht aber wir sind noch nicht
mal gegen die eu wenn man die richtig
gestaltet ist das ein sinnvolles projekt
aber da muss man sie richtig gestalten
und so falsch wie sie jetzt ist so kann
sie nicht bleiben
wenn es so weiter geht dann wird dexxit
irgendwann kommen dann wird die eu
sowieso zusammenbrechen darum müssen wir
sie reformieren
das werden aber nicht die tun die ist
die ganze zeit falsch machen
insofern müssen dann neue köpfe hin die
es anders machen wollen und diese neuen
köpfe das sind wir wir brauchen hier
veränderungen und lassen sie mich ein
letztes dazu sagen inhaltlich wir
brauchen eine festung europa es wird
darunter nicht gehen wenn wir die
freiheit im inneren bewahren wollen
brauchen wir ganz klare außengrenzen wie
müssen funktionieren dass wir die afd
sind angetreten um die
familienpolitische und
bildungspolitische geisterfahrt der ms
deutschland endlich zu beenden müsste
ich gebe ihnen beispielen wo ihre
steuergelder ihre hart verdienten so
hingehen 115 millionen euro das ja keine
peanuts sind uns alle einig also 115
millionen ist schon ein ganzer batzen
das geht in das wunderbare projekt
demokratie leben dass es eines dieser
tollen projekte die diese durch
couragierte jugend da hinten so
verstrahlt dass sie mind andersdenkende
übertönen und nicht anhören zu müssen
die deutungshoheit über andere leute
meinungen gewinnen zu müssen solche
tollen slogans zu propagieren wie das
sei keine meinung und was hast ist das
definieren wir
absoluter schwachsinn also vom
kindergarten bis zur professur wird
durch ideologisiert und das geht schon
in den kindergärten los das betrifft sie
ihre kinder ihre enkel ihre nichten und
neffen in kindergärten sollen nun
kindergärtnerinnen schauen wer zöpfe
trägt welche jungs durchtrainiert sind
das ist alles verdächtig zu völkischen
gedankengut das ist alles verdächtig
andersdenkende und nichtregierungs treu
zu sein und wissen sich mein das kannten
sehr vielleicht schon dann stehen
gespräche mit eltern an womöglich
womöglich müssen sie ihre kinder dann
anders frisieren keine ahnung unsere
politischen gegner die uns
undemokratische nennen sind selbst und
demokraten und versuchen uns mit
undemokratischen mitteln von den plätzen
und straßen unserer heimat zu vertreiben
aber ihr die her steht ihr seid hier
zusammen gekommen und wir senden ein
zeichen wir lassen uns nicht vertreiben
nicht durch hetze nicht durch dritte
nicht durch schläge und nicht durch eure
lügen denn die wahrheit bricht sich bahn
wir dürfen uns nicht daran gewöhnen dass
in unserem land eine klima hetze
betrieben wird die mittlerweile
religiösen charakter angenommen hat ich
habe es im bundestag bereits einmal
gesagt die grünen sind eine klima sekte
sie haben sich nicht entblödet mit ihrer
mit ihrem parteimitglied frau
göring-eckardt greta thunberg als eine
art propheten hinzustellen und damit
haben sie sich enttarnt sie haben
nämlich offenkundig dargelegt dass es
ihnen nicht um den schutz irgend eines
klimas auf wissenschaftlicher grundlage
gilt sondern dass sie sich einen
religiösen unangreifbarkeit nimbus
zulegen wollen und diesen nimbus den
werden wir mit dem scharfen schwert der
wissenschaft aus dem feld finden denn in
sachen klima ist
eine neue aufklärung denn ganz europa
geboten und wir werden sie einleiten
volker krönert liebe es so wie es die
umfragen jetzt prognostizieren 13 12 13
prozent für die fdp wäre das im
vergleich zur letzten europawahl ein
extrem erfolgreicher wahlabend das
beschränkt sich aber nicht nur auf
deutschland oder was die populistische
parteien angeht nein
in europa gehört das ganze spektrum
euro-skeptische nationalkonservativer
rechts konservativer parteien sicherlich
zu den gewinnern dieser wahl
zugleich aber gibt es so viele
unterschiede in dieser ganzen formation
dass sie im grunde mit ihrem sieg dazu
beitragen werden dass wieder eine
variante einer großen koalition am ende
doch bestimmt was in europa geschehen
wird sie werden als das gegenteil von
dem erreichen was sie wünschen
zurzeit ist dieses ganze rechte spektrum
eingeteilt in drei fraktionen von denen
die eine sehr stark geprägt war von der
uk partei die den exit gewünscht hat nun
sind die briten immer noch da und die
neue praxis fort partei von fahrrad wird
wieder ins europäische parlament
einziehen stärker und stärker als tories
und labour tories im europäischen
parlament aber zu haben
zusammen mit der er wehrte konservativen
polnischen partei recht und
gerechtigkeit wird dazu führen dass sich
das ganze spektrum rechts kritischer
rechtskonservativer rechtsnationale oder
euro skeptischer parteien kaum zu einer
einzelnen fraktionen einzigen fraktionen
zusammen tun wird würden sie das
schaffen so werden sie möglicherweise
sogar die stärkste fraktion nach den
umfragen die wir kennen aber das
spektrum ist sehr groß in diesem ganzen
bereich so dass man eher davon ausgehen
muss dass es vermutlich zwei gruppen
gegeben wird eine eher euro-skeptische
nationalkonservative und eine
rechtsnationale nationalistische
fraktion angeführt von der italienischen
lega die vermutlich die stärkste
einzelpartei überhaupt im europäischen
parlament stellen will und die deutsche
afd
wird sicher dieser gruppe anschließen
das sind eine ganze reihe von parteien
die nicht nur opposition um der
opposition willen betreiben
einige von ihnen etwa die fpö sind ja in
regierungsverantwortung in ihren ländern
also dieses wahlergebnis wird das
regieren und die mehrheitsbildung in
europa noch komplizierter machen aber es
wird auch ein ehrliches abbild der
pluralistischen vielfalt der diskussion
sein den die manager noch auf die
deutsche fdp ganz kurzem hat sich ja
sehr abgearbeitet an kommission soder
dem kommissions- kandidaten manfred
weber ein deutscher kandidat trotzdem in
deutschland funktioniert es scheinbar
nicht die union ist er bei 33 ein
bisschen drunter sogar warum
funktioniert das so gut für die afg dann
in diesem fall sich soweit zu
profilieren und gegebenenfalls einen
erfolgreichen wahlen zu gestalten ja
weil die parteien der sogenannten
politischen mitte eben seit einer ganzen
reihe von jahren jetzt wie ein kaninchen
auf die schlange dieser neuen bewegungen
geblickt haben die sich längst in
politischer das gleiche finden sich auch
bei der bundestagswahl zeigen wiederholt
sich in europa auch in vielen anderen
ländern
zum teil geht es richtig um machtkämpfe
wer auf platz eins in einem land ist
etwa in frankreich wo die fassung limo
national die ehemalige von national
versucht die nummer eins zu werden den
staatspräsidenten im wahlergebnis
abzulösen jedenfalls die wahlergebnis
auch in anderen ländern haben wir
ähnliche konstellationen wie sich das
eben auch in der in den deutschen
wahlkampf die da widerspiegelt und diese
ablehnung gegenüber der svp respektive
der cdu ist ja im grunde genommen auch
ein selbst gesetzter schnitt der afg
damit es unter keinen umständen auch aus
ihrer sicht irgendwie zu
koalitionsbildungen zwischen allen
rechts von der mitte befindlichen auch
die liberal- konservativen
christdemokraten kommt ein projekt für
das der ungarische premierminister orban
immer noch wirkt in der hoffnung das
ganze die ganze das ganze spektrum der
euro skeptiker und rechts konservativ
mit der svp zu einer sozusagen rechten
mehrheit zusammen zu schmieden
auch das wird jedenfalls bei diesem
wahlkampf führen die wir hier hören von
beiden seiten her nicht
dillingen insofern bleiben die
koalitionsbildungen mühsam aber sie
werden sich in der politischen mitte
abspielen und dann natürlich wieder
wasser auf die mühlen der eher
kritischen und extremistischen
positionen seien die genau diese art von
großer koalition immer sehr leicht
verdammen ein leichtes auch haben die
sie zu verdammen
ich befürchte aus diesem kreislauf
werden wir auch nach der nächsten
nach der wahl in zwei wochen nicht
wirklich heraus kommen wahrscheinlich
deshalb gibt es gleich am dienstag
darauf nämlich am 28 den sondergipfel wo
dann die staats und regierungschefs über
dieses wahlergebnis beraten ich sagt
herzlichen dank professor